Platon n’est pas là !
Tu te rends compte, Haristote ?
Il n’est pas là alors que Socrate,
son maître qu’il idolâtre,
s’apprête à mourir.
Quand le gardien de la prison vient dire
que c’est l’heure de boire le poison,
tout le monde est là.
Impossible de manquer Xanthippe,
la femme de Socrate,
qui se lamente bruyamment
- au point qu’elle sera mise dehors.
Quant aux disciples,
ils sont TOUS là,
à l’exception notable de Xénophon,
le rival de Platon,
qui écrira aussi sur Socrate
- mais Xénophon, lui,
a une bonne excuse :
il est en campagne militaire en Asie -
et puis il manque aussi Aristippe de Cyrène,
qui fondera l’hédonisme,
parce qu’il est…
...comment dire…
« en voyage d’affaires ».
Mais surtout,
Platon n’est pas là !
Platon,
l’héritier surdoué d’une famille
dont on dit qu’elle est la plus riche
et la plus puissante politiquement
à Athènes
- cet héritier
qui a renoncé,
dans un premier temps,
à un destin tout tracé
qui l’aurait mené au pouvoir,
puis,
dans un second temps,
à ses rêves d’artiste.
Et il a renoncé à tout
POUR QUOI ?
Pour suivre un demi-clochard
qui a une réputation d’escroc !
Platon a renoncé
À TOUT
pour se consacrer à Socrate,
mais au moment
LE PLUS IMPORTANT
de la vie de son maître...
il est absent.
Tu te rends compte,
Haristote ?
D’après la version officielle,
Platon est malade…
MOUAIS…
on n’a pas retrouvé le certificat médical…
La vérité est beaucoup plus compliquée.
La VÉRITÉ,
c’est que si Platon avait été présent
avec tous les autres
auprès de Socrate,
nous n’aurions peut-être JAMAIS
entendu parler
ni de Socrate
ni de Platon.
Mettez-vous à la place de Platon :
l’homme grâce auquel vous avez trouvé
le sens de votre vie,
- un homme que vous vénérez
plus que tout -
cet homme si important pour vous,
qui est plus qu’un père,
cet homme a été condamné à mort,
et vous l’avez abandonné
DANS SES DERNIERS INSTANTS.
L’absence de Platon,
c’est la clé pour comprendre
le MYSTÈRE Socrate.
Rendez-vous compte :
Socrate,
c’est un fils d’ouvrier
au physique repoussant,
à la réputation exécrable à Athènes,
et qui n’a rien écrit
- c’est CET HOMME-LÀ
dont le nom est presque devenu
synonyme
de « philosophie ».
Pour comprendre ce qui s’est passé,
il faut revenir aux origines.
Je vais donc vous raconter
Socrate
comme vous ne le connaissez pas.
Je vais notamment vous révéler
les raisons cachées de la mauvaise réputation
du père de la philosophie
les secrets maquillés par les disciples,
les ressorts du complot
qui a abouti à la condamnation à mort de
Socrate,
et puis SURTOUT
vous comprendrez à la fin de la vidéo
la raison de l’absence INEXPLICABLE
de Platon,
et les conséquences INCROYABLES
qu’elle aura dans l’histoire de la philosophie.
À la fin de cette vidéo,
vous ne verrez plus Socrate
de la même manière ;
et votre regard sur la philosophie
aura changé.
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec mon fidèle Haristote,
avec un H,
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Tu pourrais être un peu plus présentable…
Ça fait plusieurs mois qu’on n’a pas
fait de vidéo…
T’as même pas reconnu le prompteur,
t’as aboyé…
Je vais commencer par vous raconter
les origines ÉTONNANTES
de Socrate,
mais je dois d’abord vous dire rapidement
trois petites choses
qui vont vous intéresser.
Tout d’abord,
je vous propose de télécharger ma synthèse
des 100 meilleures idées philosophiques.
Que vous soyez étudiant ou pas,
c’est un moyen efficace
de découvrir facilement
ou de revoir rapidement
les idées majeures de l’histoire de la
pensée
- dont bien sûr
celles de Socrate.
La deuxième petite chose que j’ai à vous
dire,
c’est que je compte faire d’autres vidéos
sur les vies des plus grands philosophes
- j’ai déjà commencé pour Platon,
Aristote,
Voltaire,
et Satre -
donc abonnez-vous à la chaîne YouTube
si ça vous intéresse,
et puis dites-moi dans les commentaires
quels sont les philosophes
dont vous aimeriez découvrir la vie.
Enfin,
dernière précision :
dans cette vidéo,
je vais uniquement vous raconter
la VIE de Socrate
en me focalisant sur les aspects MÉCONNUS,
donc si vous voulez plus de détails
ou si vous vous intéressez
aux IDÉES de Socrate,
je vous ai mis tout le nécessaire
dans la description de la vidéo.
Vous y trouverez aussi mes sources,
et j’y ai également ajouté le minutage
de la vidéo,
donc n’hésitez pas à la regarder en plusieurs
fois,
si vous préférez.
Voilà, c’est bon !
Je peux maintenant vous raconter
les origines ÉTONNANTES de Socrate.
Vous savez pourquoi les disciples
en parlent si peu ?
Parce que c’est la LÉGENDE
qu’ils veulent vous servir.
Le mystère Socrate commence
avec ses origines.
Ses disciples n’en parlent pas beaucoup,
et ils essaient peut-être même
de les CACHER,
car les ADVERSAIRES
de Socrate,
utilisent ses origines
CONTRE lui,
pour le discréditer.
Ils répandent par exemple la rumeur
qu’il est un fils d’esclave,
c’est-à-dire qu’il ne serait pas
un VRAI
citoyen athénien.
Alors cette rumeur
est fausse,
mais quel est le problème
avec les origines de Socrate ?
Le PROBLÈME,
c’est que Socrate est un fils D’OUVRIER
qui évolue dans un milieu
ARISTOCRATIQUE,
et cela dans une société où
la valeur des ancêtres
rejaillit sur l’héritier.
À Athènes,
être le fils de quelqu’un
SUFFIT
à être quelqu’un
et à exercer un ascendant social.
Bien sûr,
c’est toujours le cas
dans les sociétés occidentales,
mais dans une moindre mesure
par rapport à l’Antiquité grecque.
Par exemple,
la famille de Platon est si prestigieuse
qu’il ne révèle pas son nom
lors des compétitions de lutte
pour qu’on le laisse tranquille.
Dans le détail,
cependant,
le rapport entre les classes sociales
est paradoxal à Athènes :
d’un côté,
ce n’est pas un système de castes ;
la cité est ouverte,
tout le monde se côtoie
et se fréquente plutôt librement ;
MAIS de l’autre,
les aristocrates font preuve
un véritable mépris de classe
à l’égard du peuple athénien.
Or Socrate,
LUI,
n’est le fils de personne.
Il naît en -470
de l’union d’une sage-femme,
Phénarète,
et d’un ouvrier sculpteur,
Sophronisque.
Ses origines sont donc très modestes
- on ne peut probablement pas faire
plus modeste
dans l’Athènes de l’époque.
Sage-femme,
c’était un métier subalterne,
et la plupart des accoucheuses
étaient des esclaves
- la rumeur selon laquelle Socrate était
un esclave
vient peut-être de là.
Quant à son père,
Sophronisque,
ce n’était pas vraiment un artisan,
mais un ouvrier sans talent
qui sculptait grossièrement le marbre
des carrières à côté desquelles
vivait la famille.
En clair,
la famille vit dans la pauvreté :
le père vend quelques statuettes
par-ci par là,
et la mère ne tire pas grand chose
de ses services.
Du coup,
Socrate n’aura pas le choix :
il exercera le même métier que son père,
il sculptera le marbre pour survivre.
Il n’a tout simplement
PAS les moyens
de s’adonner à la philosophie :
il n’a pas les moyens
de ne pas travailler ;
de suivre des cours ;
et il n’a pas non plus les moyens
de VOYAGER
pour s’initier aux sagesses
qui ont influencé
la philosophie de la Grèce antique
– notamment la sagesse égyptienne.
Je caricature,
mais à l’époque,
la philosophie,
c’est un peu un truc d’enfants gâtés
– il faut avoir le frigo plein
et être blasé de la richesse
et de la gloire
qu’on n’a pas à conquérir
pour valoriser la réflexion
désintéressée.
C’est pour ÇA que
beaucoup de philosophes
sont des aristocrates
ou des fils d’hommes d’affaires prospères
;
et un destin à la Platon,
où l’héritier renonce à ses privilèges
pour se consacrer à la sagesse,
n’est en réalité
pas si exceptionnel.
Tout ça pour dire
que Socrate ne naît pas avec les bonnes cartes.
MAIS
il y a quand même des choses
que le père de la philosophie
doit à ses origines.
Il n’avait ni nom,
ni argent,
ni compétences remarquables
– seulement,
on hérite toujours de quelque chose
si on n’est pas orphelin.
Alors,
les disciples veulent vous faire croire
que leur maître est un GÉNIE
parachuté par les dieux,
un homme divin sans racines terrestres
– et peut-être ont-ils pensé à prétendre,
comme la tradition le fera pour Platon
et pour tant d’autres personnages,
que Socrate n’a pas de père.
Ils veulent vous faire croire
que le magnétisme de leur maître
est un don du ciel.
La RÉALITÉ,
c’est que Socrate est le fils de son père,
parce qu’il a GRANDI auprès de lui.
Sophronique est certes
un ouvrier MÉDIOCRE
MAIS il est exceptionnellement
SYMPATHIQUE,
il est CHARISMATIQUE.
Il est affable,
il connaît tout le monde
et parle avec tout le monde ;
sa présence est toujours agréable
aux autre ouvriers.
T’en penses quoi,
Haristote ?
Le père de Socrate est charismatique,
et lui aussi est charismatique,
il y a peut-être un lien,
non ?
À l’évidence,
Socrate tire ses grandes qualités humaines
de son père.
Et il les cultivera de la même manière :
comme son père,
il côtoie les boutiques,
il fréquente les différents artisans
– le forgeron,
le cordonnier,
le potier,
ou encore le tailleur de pierres –
ainsi que leurs ouvriers.
Il est à l’aise dans ce milieu,
au point qu’il y noue
des amitiés durables.
OR,
les disciples élevés dans les milieux
les plus privilégiés d’Athènes
auront HONTE
de ces fréquentations populaires.
Par exemple,
ils minimiseront l’affection de Socrate
pour Simon le Savetier,
un artisan fier et indépendant
qui a refusé le mécénat de Périclès.
Mais PLUS FONDAMENTALEMENT,
les disciples ne veulent pas voir
que leur maître,
cet homme toujours bien entouré
qui harcèle ses interlocuteurs de questions
dans les rues
et dans les banquets,
– ils ne veulent pas voir que cet homme,
c’est l’adolescent sociable qui,
à l’imitation de son père,
parcourait les boutiques
pour converser avec les hommes simples
et pragmatiques de sa condition.
Socrate fera ce qu’il a toujours fait :
il n’est pas un ascète
qui médite dans une grotte ;
il n’est pas fait pour la solitude,
il est comme un poisson dans l’eau
parmi les hommes,
quels qu’ils soient
On parle de la maïeutique,
sa méthode pour faire accoucher les esprits,
en référence à sa mère,
l’accoucheuse Phénarète
– mais c’est une image
ANECDOTIQUE.
À la vérité,
c’est la gouaille populaire
de son père
qui est à l’œuvre
quand le philosophe accoste les passants
et les interroge sans politesse,
sur un pied d’égalité,
sans le moindre égard pour leur statut.
APRÈS
Socrate n’a pas renié ses origines ;
au contraire,
il en était plutôt fier.
Il était sensible à
la NOBLESSE
de l’artisanat,
et il est resté dans la misère
TOUTE sa vie
parce qu’il considérait
que l’abondance
détourne de la vertu.
Ce sont LES DISCIPLES
qui ont renié,
par mépris de classe,
les origines du maître.
Et ENCORE,
ce n’est pas la seule chose
qu’ils nous ont cachée...
Imaginez la scène :
on est en 424
avant Jésus-Christ,
Socrate a quarante-six ans ;
il vient de rentrer de la bataille de Délion,
que les Athéniens ont perdu
et il assiste à la représentation
d’une comédie qui le met en scène,
Les Nuées d’Aristophane.
Exténué par le voyage
et
abattu par la défaite,
il reçoit le coup de grâce :
les MOQUERIES
du public.
Eh oui
parce qu’Aristophane n’est pas tendre
avec lui :
la pièce raconte l’histoire
d’un père accablé de dettes
qui doit rendre des comptes à la justice.
Et qu’est-ce qu’il fait
pour se tirer d’affaire ?
Il envoie son fils
apprendre des arnaques intellectuelles…
auprès de Socrate !
Comme ça, il persuadera les juges
et il évitera de payer ses créanciers.
Et il n’a aucun doute que ça va marcher,
car on dit de Socrate
qu’il est capable de faire passer pour honnête
la cause la plus crapuleuse.
Eh oui,
on parle bien de Socrate,
celui dont on dit qu’il est
le « PÈRE de la philosophie ».
Mais alors,
c’est quoi cette histoire ?
Je vous l’ai déjà dit :
à Athènes,
la réputation de Socrate est exécrable.
Alors c’est sûr qu’il est célèbre,
puisqu’il est un personnage de comédie,
mais il est célèbre
comme escroc
– on raconte qu’il apprend
à échapper à la justice.
OR,
c’est à ce type de « compétence »
entre guillemets
qu’on reconnaît
les sophistes.
Mini rappel si vous ne savez pas
qui étaient les sophistes :
c’était des professeurs de rhétorique
itinérants,
qui sont arrivés à Athènes
grosso modo à l’époque de Socrate,
et qui sont passés à la postérité
comme des intellectuels
qui n’en avaient rien à faire de la vérité
– tout ce qui comptait pour eux,
d’après l’image biaisée qu’on en a
aujourd’hui,
c’était gagner le débat
et gagner de l’argent.
Voilà,
j’ai fait simple et rapide,
donc si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
sophistes,
je vous recommande ma vidéo intitulée
« 5 raisons de réhabiliter les sophistes
»,
que vous pouvez voir
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Alors,
je vous conseille de regarder ma vidéo sur
les sophistes plus tard,
parce que j’ai encore beaucoup de choses
étonnantes
à vous révéler sur Socrate.
Je reviens donc à lui,
le mini rappel est terminé.
Dans la pièce d’Aristophane
dont Socrate est spectateur
à son retour de la guerre,
son personnage est un sophiste,
donc il faut que croire
que les Athéniens
le prennent pour un sophiste.
C’est d’autant plus probable
qu’Aristophane n’est pas le seul
à considérer Socrate comme un sophiste.
Pour Androiton,
un historien du quatrième siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
qui est donc très proche des événements,
pour cet historien,
Socrate est mort en martyr
de la sophistique,
mais « martyr » au sens
d’APÔTRE
de GRAND-PRÊTRE de la sophistique
– c’est-à-dire que Socrate était,
d’après cet historien,
LE SOPHISTE par excellence.
Autre auteur qui donne la même version :
Eschine,
le plus brillant orateur,
avec Démosthène,
du quatrième siècle avant Jésus-Christ
qui est né seulement neuf ans
après la mort de Socrate
– eh bien cet auteur appelle le philosophe
« Socrate LE SOPHISTE ».
Et je pourrais vous citer encore d’autres
auteurs
qui rangent Socrate
parmi les sophistes,
mais la devise de 1000 idées de culture générale
c’est « pas de prise de tête »,
donc je m’arrête là.
Alors,
j’imagine votre réaction :
« Non mais,
Socrate,
c’est l’ADVERSAIRE
des sophistes.
Il les dénonce
comme de faux philosophes.
»
Oui,
moi aussi j’ai appris ça
– mais encore une fois,
il s’agit de la LÉGENDE,
la version écrite
et propagée par les disciples.
Pour retrouver la vérité,
il faut prendre en considération deux choses
:
la première,
c’est que les sophistes avaient une grande
influence
dans l’Athènes de Socrate,
et donc rares sont les intellectuels
ou les auteurs
qui n’ont pas appris à leurs côtés.
C’est d’autant plus probable
que les sophistes aient formé Socrate
que leur activité intellectuelle était
PUBLIQUE
contrairement aux philosophes
qui vivaient détachés de la cité
– autrement dit,
il suffisait au jeune Socrate,
qui en plus
était habile dans les relations sociales,
il lui suffisait de s’immiscer
dans les discussions,
dans les débats,
dans les banquets mondains,
et de se faire bien voir des professeurs,
jusqu’à devenir un de leurs habitués.
Et ainsi,
lui qui n’avait pas le sou
pouvait développer
sa compétence intellectuelle
sans rien payer.
Par exemple,
il rencontre Protagoras,
le sophiste star d’Athènes,
chez le riche Callias
– il a vingt-six ans,
et il tombe sous le charme.
Il est donc assez probable que Socrate
se soit mis à la philosophie
grâce aux sophistes,
puis qu’il en soit devenu un,
parce que c’était,
pour lui,
LE SEUL MOYEN POSSIBLE
de se former.
PLUS FONDAMENTALEMENT,
la distinction entre le philosophe
et le sophiste
n’était pas aussi marquée
qu’elle l’est aujourd’hui.
Pour nous,
le philosophe
c’est un individu qui recherche la vérité
et le sophiste un menteur ;
MAIS à l’époque,
les philosophes et les sophistes
étaient en contact permanent
– ils échangeaient des idées,
des méthodes,
et des techniques –
et puis SURTOUT
des sophistes se disaient philosophes,
et des philosophes
avaient aussi une activité de sophiste.
En clair,
la frontière était TRÈS FLOUE.
Parmi les maîtres connus de Socrate,
certains,
comme Archélaos de Milet,
étaient de la première génération de philosophes
qui ont émigré à Athènes ;
d’autres étaient des sophistes,
des professeurs qui vendaient leur savoir
– MAIS encore une fois,
toutes ces personnes évoluaient
dans un même milieu intellectuel.
Ce n’est donc pas étonnant
qu’on retrouve,
si on ne souscrit pas à la légende,
l’influence des sophistes
dans la pensée de Socrate :
certains sophistes comme Prodicos
avaient déjà popularisé
la culture de la définition ;
et pour ce qui est de la dialectique de Socrate,
eh bien elle ressemble beaucoup
aux traditionnels « discours doubles »
des sophistes.
APRÈS,
Socrate et ses disciples se sont appropriés
et ont donné une autre dimension
à ces techniques philosophiques
– MAIS
ils ne les ont probablement PAS
inventées.
Donc voilà pour la première chose
à prendre en compte :
Socrate a probablement été FORMÉ
par les sophistes.
Seconde chose à prendre en compte
pour se rapprocher de la vérité :
l’âge de Socrate.
Quand Platon rencontre Socrate,
le maître a SOIXANTE ANS,
et il ne lui reste plus que
DIX ANS à vivre
– autrement dit,
Platon ne connaît que le vieux Socrate.
Il ne connaît pas
le JEUNE Socrate,
celui qu’Aristophane dépeint
comme un escroc notoire,
celui qu’on dit emporté
et provocateur,
au point qu’on en fera
un précurseur des cyniques,
ces philosophes qui érigeront le scandale
en mode de vie.
L’ADVERSAIRE des sophistes,
celui qui les dénonce,
c’est donc plutôt
le VIEUX Socrate.
Du coup,
l’hypothèse qu’on peut faire,
c’est que Socrate soit en réalité
un RENÉGAT
de la sophistique.
Socrate se serait CONVERTI
SUR LE TARD
à ce qu’il conçoit
comme la philosophie authentique,
et il aurait renié
son passé de sophiste.
Ou plutôt,
ce seraient ses disciples
qui auraient gommé
le passé de sophiste de leur maître
et renié l’héritage des sophistes
dans l’enseignement socratique.
La légende a fait de Socrate
l’ADVERSAIRE des sophistes,
MAIS il en est plutôt
le PLUS CÉLÈBRE
ÉLÈVE.
Certaines rumeurs couraient d’ailleurs
sur les motifs de sa conversion :
d’après certains qui,
forcément,
ne tenaient pas Socrate dans leur cœur,
c’est parce que sa carrière de sophiste
était un échec commercial
qu’il aurait pris
une AUTRE voie.
Bon,
ça ressemble plus à une rumeur malveillante,
mais ça confirme l’hypothèse probable
d’une conversion tardive
à la philosophie
telle qu’il l’entendra.
En tout cas,
la question de l’argent sera un contentieux
entre Socrate et les sophistes.
Le philosophe reproche aux sophistes
de monétiser leur savoir,
et donc d’avoir en vue le profit,
plutôt qu’une finalité supérieure,
plus noble.
Il conseille aux jeunes gens
de ne pas se faire avoir,
et de suivre plutôt des maîtres
qui transmettent GRATUITEMENT
leur sagesse
- comme lui, bien sûr.
Bon d’accord,
mais là je ne peux pas m’empêcher
de me demander :
d’où parle-t-il ?
de quoi vit-il, lui ?
Est-ce qu’il vit de philosophie
et d’eau fraîche ?
Alors,
Socrate ne travaille pas ;
il laisse sa femme et ses trois enfants
dans la misère ;
mais comment s’en sort-il
pour les nécessités matérielles
de l’existence ?
Eh bien,
il n’a pas,
ou plutôt
il n’a PLUS besoin
de faire le sophiste,
parce qu’il est
ENTRETENU.
Comme ses disciples sont richissimes,
il vit à leur frais.
Son principal mécène
est son camarade d’enfance Criton,
qui est une sorte de self-made man athénien
– il mettra même sa fortune en gage
pour faire évader Socrate de prison
après le procès.
Alors certes,
Socrate vit quand même petitement,
mais pour être cohérent avec son discours,
il fallait soit qu’il travaille à côté,
soit qu’il vive comme un clochard,
en renonçant totalement à l’argent.
Mais non :
lui se faisait entretenir,
et il allait dans les meilleurs banquets.
Et c’est la même chose pour Platon,
comme je l’ai déjà dit dans ma vidéo
sur les sophistes :
Platon était l’héritier de la famille
la plus riche d’Athènes ;
l’argent n’a donc jamais été un souci
pour lui,
à tel point qu’une rémunération
n’aurait eu strictement aucun intérêt.
D’ailleurs,
c’est peut-être Platon,
le disciple qui n’a pas connu Socrate le
sophiste,
et qui a vécu hors de la réalité économique,
c’est peut-être bien LUI
qui a radicalisé
la critique du maître
à l’encontre des sophistes.
En conclusion,
Socrate le défenseur de la philosophie authentique,
de la vérité et de la justice,
face aux vilains sophistes,
c’est une vision très déformée
de la réalité historique
– c’est la légende des disciples.
APRÈS,
ils ne sont pas les seuls fabricateurs
du Socrate qu’on connaît ;
la biographie du philosophe a aussi été
adaptée
aux tabous de la modernité
– c’est le cas notamment
de sa vie « sentimentale ».
Aujourd’hui,
on dirait que Socrate est
un PÉDOPHILE.
S’il y a bien une légende
qui semble correspondre à la réalité,
c’est celle sur la laideur de Socrate.
On le compare à un silène,
la créature mythologique associée à l'ivresse,
– une sorte de croisement
entre un homme rustre
et un taureau.
Socrate a de grosses lèvres,
une barbe à l’implantation sauvage,
un nez camus
(donc pas grec),
des narines dilatées,
des yeux saillants
et un front proéminent.
Pour les Grecs,
qui sacralisent la beauté physique,
c’est un choc.
Pour eux,
qui ont l’habitude de déduire
la personnalité d’un homme
de ses traits physiques,
Socrate ne peut être que débile
et débauché.
Ils interprètent son exophtalmie
(les yeux qui sortent
de leur orbite)
comme le signe d’un mélange
d’intelligence
et de sensualité.
Je ne sais pas si ça vaut aussi
pour les chiens.
D’autres commentateurs
de la physionomie de Socrate
estiment que son caractère sauvage
révèle plus précisément
un goût pour les prostitués
- effectivement,
c’est précis.
Ce qui est certain,
c’est qu’en plus de ne pas avoir été
gâté
par la nature,
le philosophe n’arrange pas les choses :
il se néglige physiquement,
à un degré qui justifierait
l’exclusion des gymnases.
Les gymnases ?
Qu’est-ce qu’un philosophe
fait dans les gymnases ?
Socrate n’y va pas pour s’entraîner,
mais pour
« MATER ».
Comme pas mal des philosophes de son époque,
il a un goût prononcé pour les petits garçons,
disons les préadolescents.
Alors,
dans la Grèce antique,
la relation homosexuelle
(prétendument « éducative »)
entre un homme adulte
(l’éraste)
et un jeune garçon
(l’éromène),
cette relation
était une institution.
C’était très répandu
dans les milieux aristocratique,
artistique,
ET philosophique.
Il y avait même une tradition de la poésie
pédérastique,
où l’éraste compose
pour l’éromène ;
et dans les écoles philosophiques,
la pédérastie se transmettait de maître
en disciple.
Socrate aurait par exemple été initié
à l’amour grec
EN MÊME TEMPS
qu’à la philosophie
par son premier maître,
Archélaos de Milet.
SEULEMENT,
pour certains témoins et auteurs de l’époque,
la relation spéciale maître-disciple
et la transmission du savoir,
c’était un peu un prétexte
pour laisser s’exprimer,
derrière un ascétisme de façade,
un instinct de prédateur.
Plutarque écrit par exemple dans Éroticos
:
« Il met en avant l’amitié et la vertu.
Il se couvre de poussière dans l’arène,
prend des bains froids,
fronce les sourcils.
À l’extérieur,
il se donne l’air d’un philosophe et d’un
sage,
à cause de la loi,
puis, la nuit,
quand tout repose,
« douce est la cueillette en l’absence
du gardien ». »
Le terrain de chasse des philosophes,
ce sont les palestres,
les lieux publics qui servent à l’entraînement
des jeunes gens.
Les rapports ont généralement lieu dans
les salles sombres
qui entourent l’espace dédié à l’exercice.
Socrate est apparemment
un pédéraste très actif.
Il est fasciné par la sensualité
des corps des lutteurs juvéniles
qui s’exercent dans les palestres.
Il tombe par exemple amoureux de Charmide,
l’oncle de Platon,
un très beau garçon,
fragile et influençable,
de dix-treize ans
qu’il avait déjà remarqué plusieurs années
auparavant
(Platon restera pudique
à propos de cette relation).
Socrate aura également une relation
avec le jeune lutteur vedette Lysis,
alors âgé de quatorze ans.
MAIS SURTOUT,
Socrate multiplie les « amants » parmi ses
disciples,
qui sont sous son charme.
On peut citer notamment
Phèdre,
Euthydème,
Agathon,
Critobule,
Autolycos,
Anytos,
et le fameux Alcibiade.
L’attrait que le maître
exerce sur ses disciples est tel
qu’Antisthène,
le futur fondateur de l’école cynique,
n’hésite pas à faire CHAQUE JOUR
les dix-huit kilomètres
du trajet aller-retour du Pirée.
Socrate n’a pas vraiment de limites,
car il a même une relation
avec Critobule,
LE FILS de son mécène Criton qui,
on peut le comprendre,
ne voit pas ça d’un très bon oeil.
La dimension pédérastique de l’enseignement
socratique
est notoire à Athènes :
les jeunes gens savent que
pour apprendre la sagesse auprès du philosophe,
il faut « passer sous le manteau »,
le fameux manteau sâle et défraîchi de
Socrate,
qu’il porte été comme hiver,
et qui sert donc AUSSI
aux ébats avec les éromènes.
On raconte que les cours particuliers DÉRAPENT
parfois,
et il n’est pas rare qu’on surprenne le
maître
à épier de jeunes garçons.
À en croire les témoignages,
Socrate était donc aussi
un pervers.
Alors,
encore une fois,
je sais bien,
comme je l’ai déjà dit,
que la pédérastie était une institution
dans la Grèce antique.
SEULEMENT,
la manière dont les philosophes
– et en particulier Socrate –
la pratiquaient
– en se servant de leur autorité morale
et de leur intelligence –
cette manière indignait déjà des témoins
de l’époque
et des historiens qui n’ignoraient pas
la place de la pédérastie
dans la société athénienne.
Je vous ai par exemple cité
la réprobation de Plutarque,
un penseur majeur de la Rome antique,
qui se situe pourtant,
philosophiquement parlant,
dans la filiation de Socrate
et de Platon.
Pour être encore plus précis,
moi je ne me place pas
dans une posture morale,
je ne dis pas :
« Oh la la,
Socrate était un pervers pédophile ! »
Non,
ce que je veux,
c’est souligner le grand contraste entre,
d’une part,
l’image que nous avons de Socrate
– image qui a été façonnée par les disciples,
puis filtrée par les tabous de la modernité
–
et d’autre part,
la réalité historique.
D’après les biographies,
d’après les témoignages,
Socrate n’était pas le sage
qu’on peut imaginer,
le maître qui domine ses passions,
l’homme EXCLUSIVEMENT
épris de vérité.
Bien sûr,
il y a là aussi,
comme pour le conflit avec les sophistes,
une question d’âge.
On peut raisonnablement penser
que la passion pédérastique de Socrate
a FAIBLI avec les années,
et c’est peut-être même
du silence du corps
qu’a émergé la théorie socratique d’un
amour noble
que Platon présente dans Le Banquet.
D’ailleurs on ne sait pas,
de ce que j’ai lu,
si Platon,
qui est un disciple tardif de Socrate,
est passé lui aussi
« sous le manteau »
– mais comme il approchait la vingtaine,
il était peut-être trop vieux
au goût de son maître.
Autre élément révélateur
de l’évolution de Socrate :
il a « pris femme »,
comme on dit,
assez tard.
C’est dans sa cinquantaine
qu’il a épousé Xanthippe,
une Athénienne de bonne famille
qu’on prétend liée à Périclès.
Alors,
on ne sait pas trop POURQUOI
il a décidé de se marier
– certains font l’hypothèse que c’est
par « civisme »,
pour combler le vide démographique
creusé par la guerre du Péloponnèse.
En tout cas,
il n’y a pas eu de coup de foudre,
ni de jeux de séduction
comme dans les gymnases
avec les lutteurs prépubères.
Le Socrate des vingt dernières années,
celui qui s’apprête à connaître Platon,
n’est PLUS
le même Socrate.
Il est loin des excès de sa jeunesse,
il s’est écarté des sophistes,
il ne poursuit probablement plus les jeunes
garçons
de ses assiduités
– SEULEMENT,
les gens n’oublient pas comme ça.
On raconte que Socrate a changé
lorsqu’il s’est vu tourné en dérision,
en sophiste escroc,
dans la pièce d’Aristophane
– on dit que c’est à CE MOMENT
qu’il a embrassé son destin,
sa mission philosophique.
SEULEMENT,
on ne se refait pas une virginité comme ça,
et Athènes
a la mémoire longue.
On n’efface pas le passé.
Maintenant on est en 323
avant Jésus-Christ,
soit soixante-seize ans
APRÈS la mort de Socrate.
Aristote,
– non pas toi,
le disciple de Platon,
qui était le disciple de Socrate –
Aristote fuit Athènes
parce qu’il se sent menacé.
Il part avec sa famille à CHALCIS,
une île à quatre-vingt kilomètres d’Athènes,
et il dit :
« je ne laisserai pas les Athéniens
commettre un second crime
contre la philosophie.
»
Le premier crime,
c’est la condamnation à mort de Socrate.
Soixante-seize ans après,
Aristote y pense encore,
l’INJUSTICE
est encore présente dans son esprit.
Et sa remarque est d’autant plus appropriée
que ce qu’il lui arrive
RESSEMBLE
à ce qui était arrivé à Socrate
– c’est un complot du même ordre
qui se trame.
Revenons soixante-seize ans en arrière.
Nous sommes en 399
avant Jésus-Christ.
En février,
un jeune poète du nom de Mélétos
remet à l’archonte-roi
une plainte contre Socrate :
« Socrate est coupable
de ne pas croire aux dieux reconnus par l’État
et d’introduire de nouvelles divinités
;
il est en outre coupable
de corrompre les jeunes gens.
Peine : la mort.
»
C’est l’accusation typique qu’on porte
contre CEUX
dont on veut se débarrasser.
Trente-huit ans plus tôt,
Anaxagore,
le tout premier philosophe à s’établir
à Athènes,
a été condamné à mort pour impiété,
après quoi il s’est exilé,
grâce à l’aide de Périclès,
à six-cent kilomètres de là.
Soixante-seize ans après le procès de Socrate,
l’histoire se répète avec Aristote,
lui aussi visé pour impiété,
et qui choisit la même solution
qu’Anaxagore.
En 399,
Socrate lui non plus
n’est plus en odeur de sainteté à Athènes,
et il y a plusieurs raisons à cela.
Il y a tout d’abord
sa vie quotidienne :
Socrate,
c’est quand même un genre de clochard
qui harcèle les gens dans la rue,
qui leur parle sans politesse,
sans respect pour leur statut,
et qui les rabaisse
en leur montrant qu’ils ne savent rien
– je caricature un peu,
mais la maïeutique dans les rues d’Athènes,
c’est ça.
Pardon pour ma vulgarité,
mais ce qu’il faut comprendre,
c’est que Socrate « FAIT CHIER » les gens,
notamment les bourgeois
qui n’ont rien demandé,
et parmi lesquels
il se fait de véritables ennemis.
Ça c’est pour la forme,
mais il y a le fond aussi :
les idées de Socrate dérangent.
Il critique la démocratie
alors qu’elle vient d’être rétablie
;
son fameux démon personnel
heurte le religieusement correct ;
il remet en cause
les vertus traditionnelles ;
et puis son détachement à l’égard de
la politique
passe pour de l’égoïsme.
L’attitude et les idées de Socrate
en font une cible facile
dans le contexte politique tendu
de l’après-guerre du Péloponnèse,
une guerre qui a duré vingt-huit ans.
La masse bourgeoise n’en a rien à faire
de l’enseignement de Socrate,
de sa dialectique
et de sa morale
– ce qu’elle veut,
c’est pouvoir de nouveau
faire du business tranquillement,
s’enrichir de manière prévisible,
sans troubles politiques.
OR,
elle pense que le philosophe menace cette
ambition.
À en croire Platon,
Socrate a bien conscience
qu’il n’a pas beaucoup de fans
à Athènes.
À la fin du Gorgias,
Socrate s’imagine
qu’on le condamne à mort,
et il se défend en se comparant
à un médecin condamné par des enfants,
les Athéniens :
« Je serai jugé comme le serait un médecin
accusé devant des enfants par un cuisinier.
Enfants,
je n’ai fait tout cela
que pour vous conserver la santé.
»
La seconde partie de l’accusation
– « il est en outre coupable
de corrompre les jeunes gens. » –
cette partie
fait référence au destin funeste
de certains disciples de Socrate
qui étaient du parti oligarchique.
Ce sont surtout les trahisons d’Alcibiade
et Critias,
deux aristocrates brillants mais débauchés,
sans scrupules,
prêts à tout pour faire avancer leur propre
intérêt
– ce sont surtout ces deux destins
qui sont encore dans toutes les têtes
et qui entachent la réputation,
déjà bien mauvaise,
de Socrate.
Mais bon,
il faut se mettre un peu à la place des Athéniens
:
si des disciples sont capables de tels actes,
qu’est-ce que ça dit
sur l’enseignement ÉTHIQUE
du maître ?
Alors,
Socrate dira simplement
qu’il a échoué à former ces deux diables,
mais la suspicion des Athéniens
n’est pas stupide dans l’absolu :
tout comme la culpabilité du fils
peut rejaillir sur le père,
celle du disciple peut rejaillir
sur le maître.
APRÈS,
Socrate a eu beaucoup de disciples
dans l’élite athénienne,
et des DEUX côtés
– dans le parti oligarchique,
MAIS AUSSI dans le parti démocratique.
L’accusation prend ce qui l’arrange
parce que son but n’est pas de juger Socrate,
mais de s’en débarrasser.
En effet,
le procès a tout d’un complot :
plusieurs personnes se sont entendues secrètement
pour se débarrasser de Socrate
dans l’intérêt de la bourgeoisie athénienne.
Mélétos,
le jeune poète qui a déposé la plainte,
est un accusateur de paille.
L’homme qui tire les ficelles s’appelle
Anytos.
C’est un tanneur qui a fait fortune
et qui milite pour le retour à une démocratie
tempérée,
un bon régime pour le business.
Un procès représente plusieurs risques pour
lui
– en termes de temps passé,
de réputation,
et d’argent en cas d’échec –
donc il sous-traite l’accusation
à deux hommes médiocres.
Celui qui prend sur lui les risques de l’accusation,
c’est Mélétos,
que j’ai déjà évoqué :
c’est un poète raté de trente ans,
qui donne surtout dans la poésie érotique,
et dont les œuvres sont si mauvaises
qu’elles sont sifflées
et que le nom même de « Mélétos »
est devenu une insulte.
Il faut ajouter que,
comme beaucoup de poètes de l’époque,
il est JALOUX
de l’autorité morale des philosophes.
Celui qui,
dans le complot,
va instruire l’affaire,
c’est-à-dire porter la parole de l’accusation,
c’est l’orateur à gages Lycon.
Cet homme en veut à Socrate
pour la mort de son fils prodige Autolycos,
autrefois célébré dans les milieux les
plus élitistes de la cité
pour son exceptionnelle beauté
et ses exploits sportifs
Ce fils
en lequel il avait placé de grands espoirs,
ce fils dont il était dépendant pour son
ascension sociale,
a été tué par les Trente tyrans,
le gouvernement oligarchique qui a dirigé
Athènes
pendant moins d’un an,
en moins 404
- dès lors,
comme son fils a été victime de ce gouvernement,
il voudra se venger de toute personne liée,
de près ou de loin,
à l’établissement de la tyrannie.
OR,
je vous l’ai dit,
plusieurs des têtes de proue du régime
étaient des disciples de Socrate
– donc Lycon considère
que le philosophe est en partie RESPONSABLE
de l’assassinat de son fils.
Il a également une raison plus directe
d’accepter le deal d’Anytos,
c’est qu’il est LUI-MÊME
soupçonné de trahison
- pour lever les soupçons,
il doit donc donner des gages
de son allégeance à la démocratie.
Donc les deux hommes de paille,
Mélétos,
qui porte l’accusation,
et Lycon,
qui va porter LA PAROLE de l’accusation,
ces deux hommes ont tous deux
à la fois un intérêt IMMÉDIAT
dans le complot
ET un ressentiment
à l’encontre de Socrate.
C’est le cocktail parfait.
C’est aussi le cas du cerveau du complot,
Anytos.
Il a d’abord un conflit personnel avec Socrate
:
il lui reproche d’avoir dit à son fils
qu’il était trop intelligent
pour reprendre l’affaire paternelle,
et que s’il le faisait,
il sombrerait dans l’alcoolisme.
Il n’en fallait pas plus
pour le convaincre
de la dangerosité du philosophe,
qui dresse les fils contre les pères.
Mais au-delà du conflit personnel,
le riche industriel est l’ANTITHÈSE sociologique
de Socrate :
il est riche,
influent,
volontaire,
et pragmatique,
quand le philosophe est pauvre,
indifférent,
sceptique,
et passif.
APRÈS,
il n’y a probablement personne
qui tire les ficelles d’encore plus loin
derrière Anytos,
parce que cet homme d’affaires
est à lui seul très influent
dans la démocratie athénienne,
où il achète des magistrats,
des orateurs,
voire des juges.
C’est sûr que se débarrasser de Socrate
arrangera bien des gens,
mais Anytos le fait pour lui,
parce qu’il est convaincu
que c’est la bonne chose à faire.
Maintenant que j’ai décrit
les ressorts immédiats du complot,
je dois préciser quelques nuances.
La première,
c’est que le projet était en réalité
plutôt modéré :
Anytos,
qui était un démocrate convaincu,
se serait satisfait de l’exil de Socrate,
et c’est probablement le scénario
qu’il imaginait,
parce qu’il était de coutume,
dans les procès de l’époque,
en cas de condamnation,
de choisir la sanction proposée par l’accusé.
En clair,
si Socrate avait proposé de partir d’Athènes,
la solution aurait probablement été retenue,
et il aurait été sauvé.
SEULEMENT,
ça ne s’est pas passé comme ça,
et on arrive à la seconde nuance :
Socrate a MULTIPLIÉ
les provocations,
son attitude relève presque
de l’AUTOSABOTAGE.
Il n’a pas préparé son discours,
et il a même refusé celui écrit pour lui
par Lysias,
qui était le meilleur avocat athénien de
l’époque.
Il parle très simplement aux jurés,
en ignorant les attendus de l’éloquence
judiciaire,
et il ne donne aucun gage de bonne volonté.
Enfin,
il use de sa méthode habituelle
qui a l’effet habituel
sur une partie de l’audience :
ses questions ÉNERVENT.
Et pourtant,
MALGRÉ son attitude,
il n’est condamné
qu’à une faible majorité !
Sur les 501 jurés du tribunal,
281 le déclarent coupable
et 220 l’acquittent
(ce qui fait,
en pourcentage,
un rapport 56-44).
À en juger par ce résultat,
le complot a failli échouer
et on peut imaginer
qu’avec un peu de bonne volonté,
Socrate aurait gagné le procès.
Anytos savait que l’accusation était fragile,
c’est pour ça qu’il est passé
par deux hommes de paille.
Mais l’authenticité de Socrate
lui a facilité la tâche :
le philosophe est jugé coupable,
il ne reste plus qu’à déterminer la sanction.
Et comme je vous l’ai dit,
à ce stade,
il peut encore se sauver
en proposant une peine raisonnable,
l’exil
– comme Anaxagore avant lui,
comme Aristote après lui,
il peut terminer sa vie,
tranquille,
loin d’Athènes.
C’est mal le connaître :
au lieu de saisir sa chance,
il commet une dernière provocation :
comme sentence,
il propose...
une récompense :
« Qu’est-ce qui peut convenir à un bienfaiteur
pauvre
qui a besoin de loisirs
pour vous exhorter ?
Il n’est rien, Athéniens,
qui convienne mieux à un tel homme
que d’être nourri au Prytanée.
»
« Être nourri au Prytanée »,
c’était la récompense traditionnelle
des plus grands bienfaiteurs d’Athènes.
Autrement dit,
Socrate INSULTE les jurés,
ce qui relève du SUICIDE
quand la peine proposée par l’accusation
est la peine de mort.
Radicalisés par cette dernière provocation,
les jurés votent la peine de mort
à une large majorité :
361 voix
contre 140,
soit 72 pour cent.
Le complot d’Anytos a finalement réussi
au-delà de ses espérances.
D’une accusation très fragile,
sans faits précis
à reprocher à l’accusé,
sans preuves matérielles,
avec le concours
de deux hommes médiocres,
contre un philosophe éloquent,
détaché des partis politiques,
et qui bénéficie de soutiens
dans l’élite athénienne –
malgré TOUTES ces forces contraires,
Anytos a RÉUSSI
à faire condamner à mort
l’individu dont il voulait se débarrasser.
C’est tout simplement
parce que Socrate n’a PAS voulu
jouer le jeu.
Le complot a réussi
grâce à la complicité
DE LA VICTIME.
Mais le plus important
est encore à venir.
Comment Platon peut-il être absent ?
Comment peut-on être absent
à la mort de l’homme
auquel on va consacrer son œuvre ?
Mmm
est-ce qu’il ne faudrait pas plutôt
poser la question
dans l’AUTRE sens :
POURQUOI consacrer son œuvre
à l’homme qu’on n’a pas jugé bon
d’accompagner à la mort ?
Paradoxalement,
c’est Platon LUI-MÊME
qui racontera dans le Phédon,
sans avoir été le témoin direct des scènes,
la dernière journée
et les dernières confidences
de Socrate.
Et il a bien fait son travail,
parce que la valeur historique du récit
n’a pas été remise en cause.
En réalité,
il ne s’est rien passé d’exceptionnel.
La peine a été exécutée comme prévu :
le gardien-chef a apporté le poison ;
Socrate l’a bu sans attendre ;
il a ensuite marché dans la cellule
jusqu’à sentir une pesanteur
dans les jambes ;
il s’est alors allongé
pour laisser le poison agir
jusqu’au bout.
D’ailleurs,
l’événement est passé quasi INAPERÇU
dans la cité.
Des disciples ont créé la légende
des « remords » d’Athènes,
légende selon laquelle les lieux préférés
du philosophe
auraient été fermés en signe de deuil
et les accusateurs condamnés par l’opinion
publique
– cette légende est une AFFABULATION.
En réalité,
les choses n’avaient pas changé à la mort
du philosophe,
elles avaient peut-être même empiré :
les idées de Socrate dérangeaient encore.
Immédiatement après le décès,
les disciples fuient la cité par prudence.
Platon part à Mégare,
à cinquante kilomètres d’Athènes
où il rejoint son ami Euclide
dit « de Mégare »,
et ils parlent de leur maître
qu’ils viennent de perdre.
Apparemment,
c’est à cette époque que Platon renonce
DÉFINITIVEMENT
à écrire de la poésie
ou de la tragédie,
et que le projet d’offrir une postérité
à Socrate
mûrit en lui.
Il a renoncé à tout pour lui,
il est devenu son disciple,
il a fui avec les autres,
et maintenant
il veut le faire passer à la postérité
ALORS QU’IL était absent…
Lui seul savait la véritable raison,
mais on peut en imaginer deux.
Il a peut-être craint,
lui qui tenait tant à sa réputation de sagesse,
de ne pas pouvoir maîtriser ses émotions
en assistant à la mort du maître qu’il
idolâtre,
et de fondre en pleurs
comme un vulgaire Athénien.
L’autre raison possible,
c’est qu’il se sentait menacé politiquement,
et qu’il n’avait pas envie d’être le
prochain
menacé d’une peine de mort.
Mais les autres étaient là,
eux.
Lui a manqué de courage.
Il le sait,
il culpabilise.
Et donc…
il veut se racheter.
C’est lui,
LE GRAND ABSENT de la mort de Socrate,
qui va le rendre IMMORTEL.
C’est aussi probablement le poids
de son infidélité finale
qui le rendra infidèle
à la vérité historique,
qui le poussera à transmettre de son maître
une image magnifiée,
des discours retravaillées,
et une réputation quasi blanchie.
Platon a abandonné son destin politique pour
Socrate,
il abandonne maintenant son destin artistique
pour se racheter une fidélité.
Les vingt-huit écrits de Platon incarneront
le zénith de la philosophie ;
sa pensée dominera le monde antique
et toute la philosophie occidentale ;
il forgera beaucoup des concepts
et des termes
qui seront utilisés
dans TOUTE l’histoire de la philosophie,
JUSQU’À AUJOURD’HUI.
Et il fera de Socrate,
le sage qui n’a rien écrit,
une LÉGENDE,
le « père de la philosophie ».
Alors,
est-ce qu’on peut dire
que la philosophie telle qu’on la connaît
naît du REGRET de Platon ?
C’est bien possible.
Il a suffi d’un rien…
Il DEVAIT être là ;
mais s’il avait été là…
Merci d’avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu’au
bout !
J’espère vraiment
qu’elle vous a donné une autre image de
Socrate,
et puis aussi une autre image de la philosophie,
une image moins théorique
et plus vivante.
Derrière les idées,
il y a des hommes,
et personnellement j’aime m’intéresser
aux hommes
pour accéder aux idées
et pour mieux les comprendre.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu,
donnez-lui un pouce bleu,
et puis dites-moi dans les commentaires
quels sont les philosophes
dont vous aimeriez découvrir la vie.
J’ai déjà prévu de faire une vidéo sur
celle de Platon,
donc n’hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour être prévenu quand elle sortira.
Je vous propose aussi de télécharger
ma synthèse des 100 meilleures idées philosophiques.
Que vous soyez étudiant ou pas,
c’est un moyen efficace
de découvrir facilement
ou de revoir rapidement
les idées majeures de l’histoire de la
pensée
- dont bien sûr
celles de Socrate.
Pour tout savoir de la vie de Socrate,
y compris plein d’anecdotes
qui ne sont pas dans cette vidéo,
je vous recommande la lecture de mon article
« Socrate comme vous ne le connaissez pas
»,
dont le lien est dans la description.
Vous y trouverez aussi
toutes mes synthèses sur les idées de Socrate
ainsi que mes sources.
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec mon fidèle Haristote,
qui méritera lui aussi une biographie,
et sous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Vous n’avez pas besoin
de culpabiliser comme Platon
pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée
sans vous prendre la tête.